it's an honor to be here for our good
friend and mentor and at times torment
or take a big gun and they look great
man hey thanks yeah
yeah kind of bet I haven't seen Danny
for many years these donkeys here yes
yeah yes you got my shirt on look at
their player yeah that's right you know
is is real strange tone sorry but we
were in we were in a place called
Maxfield this is 30 years ago and we
both raced for this comedy Ghassan sure
yeah and we wrestled over it and Danny
very politely I kind of grudgingly let
go and I got the shirt and it's 30 years
ago and I look I think it's time I I'm
gonna give it's all yours no what about
your shirt this guy's in shape I got a
few more folded it's 30 years old I got
to admire it can I have it yield yes now
you know what you gotta do it's put this
back on man the beard man the bit ya
know Iverson for a part and I don't know
the man is it you know youíve had a
double chin no I've got a double chin it
what you doin come are we gettin no no
no we are you were doing that man you
know but uh um God
did David Letterman story no that wasn't
the part with the beard it wasn't a
David Letterman yeah okay okay so it's
good that they can let you out of home
later no come on man
it's past your bedtime I guess I'm not
sure walking up to still and I will get
him okay okay it is elder abuse I'm
sorry okay so so we're actually were
like brothers where we live brother
electrode is like like Michael Corleone
II and friend okay who's crazy
I don't wait up you
but uh okay look man who does not know
this just uh let's talk about well then
I just want to get something on my chest
mana and this one said have to give you
man
oh oh man I'm kind of choked up I was
going through a bad time a no no no let
me finish man you know I forgive you for
doing passion to the christ without me
and well okay no come on man
too tall he was too tall but I'll give
it well I could yeah it wouldn't work
but ever since for some we need to talk
about Dig Dug
yeah that's have you done what your
favorite euro tonight we started naming
something is project two words
association hey like that okay yeah
let's write okay we're coming to mind
here we just considered superior oh yeah
we just signed um press comfort to the
White House waiting make a good good
good good good double tap sounds like a
bad porno title what would my two fisted
not even worth porno title okay
Free Willy no that's good point no time
yeah I'm a bug screwed screwed screws
yeah that's kind of describes what you
got paid for that silly oh yeah those
elaborate other man really put here here
looking back only that was all great man
I'll tell you man is something about it
you know and give it's great advice man
all the time great everybody always yeah
during an emotional scene you'd say to
me like act better and one one time like
when I was it was an emotional state
wanted me to cry and he said just you
know reach up and yank out a few no
tears and it works it does you yank out
some this have you tried that
yeah it told me the same thing yeah I
tried it really works man tears if you
sit but look here okay now but the one
thing they told me but Lethal Weapon 4
he promised us if we delete the weapon
for we both win are there
I think the original title on that
script was dick and Lauren need a third
vacation that is actually a pretty good
script yeah it wasn't wasn't good yeah
you got a script yeah you get you know
they just told me to turn up and impro
up you and that was but that's how they
look like that okay good good good yeah
but enough of their so you know there's
this something about it just you know we
can get serious nobody just everybody
that me gave you the freedom to do stuff
I mean some of the things that we came
up with the toilet see some of the
things we came you go on and on and on
and on on things when he gave us give us
more give me more give me 20 minutes
everything good yeah everyone's got a
dollar a minute
well oh listen I work with Donner six
times and and and that was in the prime
of you know what I was doing you know
before I became a broken-down old guy
who drinks in the gutter and so it like
this was in the high time so I knew good
when I saw it and I knew when I was
secure and I felt secure this man he was
a master storyteller he knew all the
technical aspects of film he's forgotten
more stuff than most of us ever learned
and now he's forgotten more stuff than
that I'm sure like we're trying to get
him off to seek get off your ass dick
and make lethal Noah we'll probably call
it flaccid weapon or lethal hemorrhoid
lethal hemorrhoid do one of those every
fantastic and uh but but you know come
on what is what's what's holding you
back run out of ideas but during all
that time you felt you felt like you
were valued you felt that your opinion
and your skills were valid he let you
run not too far he had control of the
whole thing and he knew so many aspects
all aspects of the filmmaking process
and how to make us feel secure and dealt
with as I loved his actors we loved him
back he loved his crew and it was um he
was humble he had this sign over his
door said leave your ego at the door and
there was no sign of an ego around there
and it was hard for me to walk in the
room actually but
but one if there's something true
there's true humility about the man and
we've heard story after story tonight
that sort of you know the earmarks of
humility and a great artist and you know
and when they say he changed our lives
he did change our lives and so on
and continue to do so and Danny when I
were talking about it was that time in
our places where we were just kind of
like you know yeah wandering and he sort
of pulled it all together for us he
pulled us together
hello you know it's funny just how you
just how you look back in moments in
your life and the connection that we
made here is a connection which is what
su all about this you know and and how
how for me in some sense just coming out
of you know being unsure of myself man
and essentially being there and you were
so incredibly generous man I mean
actually really really meld it's way the
way that we you know we worked off each
other in general and how Jim resourcing
so important for my own develop any
growth man I can't tell you enough well
like the same goes back to you buddy the
only man who could sleep standing up I
tell you
hahaha Wade Glover oh brother
wake up but uh but just man we love you
I mean I yeah we love you and then boy
it's such an honor to be here to say
that out loud we love you man and and
and and this is - the guy who humbly
refers himself is merely a traffic cop
when it comes to film direction he under
rates himself he's not a traffic copy -
[ __ ] genius so thanks dick thank you
very all right